MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in the last two videos, we
looked at the Dirac equation
and we looked at
solutions Dirac equations.
And in the last
lecture we found that,
along with positive
energy states,
we had those negative
energy states.
Since we cannot simply drop
them or disregard them,
we do have to find physical
interpretation for these
negative energy solutions.
The first one which
was put forward,
is the one where you think
about negative energy
states all being populated--
and that is the vacuum.
The vacuum is basically a sea
full of negative energy states
which are all populated.
So if you have a
positive energy state,
and there are electrons sitting
in this energy state here,
the electron, because of the
Pauli exclusion principle
cannot fall down into the
negative energy state.
But you are able to kick
them out, for example,
to excite them with a photon.
Very excited.
The negative energy state,
you get an electron out.
This process is then
will lend to the creation
of a positron and an
electron pair with a photon.
[INAUDIBLE] pair production.
It can also explain
undulation where
there's an empty and
a negative energy
stage where the electron just
folds into creating a photon.
So while the
interpretation is useful
and it explains pair production
and undulation processes,
they fail to explain
what this vacuum,
the sea of negative
energy state even is.
So a more useful interpretation
is one part forward that
Feynman and Stückelberg, which
came out of the discussion
of quantum field theory.
And we already discussed
this interpretation
when we looked at
Feynman [INAUDIBLE]..
So have a look at
this Feynman diagram
here where you have an
electron with a positive energy
and an electron with
a negative energy,
building a photon,
which is twice
the energy in the symmetric
configuration of the electrons
before.
And you're interpreting the
negative energy solution
here of the electron as the
electron moving backward
in time.
This is an equivalent to a
positron with a positive energy
and an electron with
a positive energy
where the positron and the
electron move forward in time.
Again, in both cases, you
see the energy of the photon
is two times the energy
of those two particles.
All right.
So this is a very
short discussion.
And we will see later on
how we use the spinodes
for antiparticles together with
spinodes for particles order
to make relations that
could have matrix element.
And so we move forward with our
discussion of Feynman rules,
this time now, with
spin-1/2 particles included.